c'est pas parce que vous avez une grande
gueule et vous criez fort que vous
arrivezur vous êes sorti des bfond on le
sait poli vous avez d apprendre à parler
seule différence la seule différence
c'est que c'est pas parce que vous
affirmez fort quelque chose que ce que
vous dites est
vrai s'il est bien un sujet sur lequel
tous nos invités ici seront d'accord et
vous-même qui nous regardez c'est que
aujourd'hui le débat le plus chaud le
sujet le plus brûlant sur l'actualité à
l'intérieur de nos frontières c'est bien
le débat sur l'immigrant et sur
l'intégration c'est on l'a vu tout
récemment dimanche dernier encore avec
l'élection de Dreux on l'a vu mercredi
avec les propositions gouvernementales
sur l'immigration on l' encore vu tout à
l'heure dans le journal de 20h avec les
propositions de Jacques Chirac et on le
voit bien à travers vos interrogations
et c'est d'abord vous que nous sommes
allés interroger écouter l'écho de ces
questions c'était dans les 48 dernières
heures un peu partout en France moi je
suis partisan du chacun chez faut qu'il
fasse un effort pour qu'on les accepte
nous d'un notre côté faut pas qu'on les
rejette automatiquement parce que c'est
des étrangers hein c'est comme partout
il y en a des bons et des mauvais on met
tout le monde dans le même sac il y en a
qui fait une bêtise tout le monde est
dans le même sac et quelle solution vous
trouveriez vous pour résoudre de
problème
aujourd'hui bah c'est renvoyer les
immigrés chez eux
quoi voilà je suis pas raciste mais mais
peut-être avec les Arabes plus qu'avec
les autres il n retourner dans leur
pays pas du tout il y en a des très bons
très bons ceux qui travaillent on les
aime bien mais il y en a beaucoup
trop plus on en aura ils se multiperont
ils auront des enfants les enfants
breront la religion des parents il
sintégreront peut-être à la France mais
pas du point de vue religieux alors il
pas une femme ils en ont plusieurs alors
comment voulez-vous et on paye les
allocations à tous ces gensl moi je
souhaite qu'il s'intègre et je pense que
ça peut très bien faire mais il faut que
ça se fasse dans la dans la paix dans le
calme dans la sérénité et pas dans la
dans la haine et dans le rejet c une
richesse pour la France il s'agit de
bien rgérer et ne pas louper le virage
qu'on est en train de vivre alors comme
vous le voyez il s'agit d'un sujet très
émotionnel très tripal chacun de nous a
son opinion sur le sujet nous avons
essayé pour préparer cette émission de
faire notre métier le plus honnêtement
possible croyez-nous et nous avons
essayé de le faire aussi dans la dignité
Etap pas été facile à partir de là
nousous sommes dit la direction la
rélection de TF1 qu'il fallait organiser
un débat avec vous représentant des
Français et des immigrés en France mais
également représentant des partis
politiques et là c'est là qu'on
commençait les problèmes les problèmes
ont été très très nombreux nous sommes
dit ce débat est organisé de temps à
autre au Parlement mais assez
furtivement il faut que tout le monde
puisse s'exprimer nous nous sommes donc
adressés à tous les partis qui ont une
représentation Parlement aire en France
et on a eu une cascade de refus on a eu
d'abord une un refus de la part du
gouvernement un refus de la part du PS
un refus de la part du PC François
Léotard qui nous avait dit oui dans un
premier temps nous a dit non finalement
Alain Jupé a fait de même je vous donner
quand même un petit résumé de leur
lettre d'excuse pierre maois ne veut pas
offrir une caution à Jean-Marie Le Pen
pour répandre son idéologie indigne de
la France George Marchet n'est pas
disposé à contribuer à la publicité de
Jean Marie Le Pen qui est prêt selon lui
à toutes les abjections dès lors qu'il
se trouve devant une caméra et une
lettre commune d'Alain Jupé de François
lotard et de pierre meignuy qui nous
disent qu'il n'accepte pas les derniers
propos de Jean-Marie Le Pen marqué par
un antisémitisme prononcé et qu'il
déplore l'absence de la majorité
gouvernementale alors chacun déplore
toujours l'absence de l'autre et c'est
ainsi qu'on organise jamais de débat ben
nous on a dit qu'on voulait quand même
qu'il y ait un débat et on a trouvé des
hommes pour débattre entre eux c'est la
première fois qu'ils vont se retrouver
face- à faceace tous les deux face- à
face Jean-Marie Le Pen qui nous a dit
oui et Bernard tapi qui nous a dit oui
alors Bernard tapi vous êtes député
apparenté socialiste dites-nous pourquoi
vous avez dit oui vous je suis apparenté
majorité
présidentielle avant de dire pourquoi
j'ai dit oui il faut dire pourquoi les
autres disent non ils sont responsables
d'une institution politique à ce titre
là quand il parlent il nengage pas que
instantanément sur le moment et le débat
de fond c'est est-ce qu'il faut
effectivement donner de la publicité
est-ce qu'il faut médiatiser Jean-Marie
Le Pen et le Fond
national je crois que personne n'a
tranché ça dans toutes les rédaction les
questions sont posées les réponses ont
jamais été les mêmes sur le fond je
crois qu'ils ont tort je crois qu'ils
ont tort la question se pose pas comme
ça les médias ne sont rien d'autre que
l'attente des lecteurs que l'attente des
auditeurs que l'attente des
téléspectateurs si jeanen fait de
l'auditeur il faut l'inviter dans les
radios s'il fait du téléspectateur il
faut l'inviter dans les télévisions
ce qui est pas bon c'est de faire les
couvertures des magazines avec
Jean-Marie Le Pen parce que l'intérieur
du magasine n'est pas lu par des gens
qui votent pour lui par contre sur les
kiosques on voit défiler en permanence
des gens qui eux sont sensibilisés par
la promotion et la notoriété qu'on lui
donne alors moi je crois que sur le fond
il faut accepter de débattre et il faut
effectivement rencontrer tous ceux qui
ont des idées qui sont contraires au
sienes par contre après il y a la forme
et la forme là elle est très discutable
elle est discutable parce que en général
je suis pas celui qui cire les pomes de
la classe politique mais ce sont quand
même des gens bien élevés ce sont quand
même des gens on une retenue et face un
débatteur comme Jean-Marie Le Pen qui un
talent incroyable pour faire prendre des
V pour des lanternes c'est vrai que de
temps en temps ils sont
désarcenéstenant pourquoi moi j'ai
accepté j'ai accepté parce que c'est
grâce à lui si je fais de la
politique il a dit un jour
Marseille et moi ça va être une grande
histoire d'amour et moi je l'aime
Marseille vraiment parce que je vibre
avec elle toutes les semaines et je me
suis dit c'est impossible de laisser ça
alors Jean-Marie lapen oui monsieur tapi
est beaucoup plus connu comme
organisateur de spectacle sportif que
comme député à l'Assemblée nationale car
je me souviens encore quand il m'a
téléphoné entre les deux tours
subreptissement comme ça en me disant
mais moi quand je serai au Parlement
vous entendrez parler de moi je crois
qu'il se donne même pas la peine
d'assister aux séances ni même à celle
de la commission des finances il ne fait
figurer ce titre que sur ses papiers
d'organisation financière ce qui aurait
d'ailleurs dû lui valoir d'être exclu du
Parlement mais Dieu merci comme il le
dit il est dans la majorité
présidentielle et il est bien vu de
l'Élysée il est bien vu du château
monsieur tapi n'a pas beaucoup d'intérêt
dans cette affaire là ce qui est
intéressant il a le courage de venir
déjà ou B il vient comme avocat il est
apparenté sur les bords et il n'a pas de
responsabilité dans ce qui s'est passé
avant il n'est venu là que pour contrer
Monsieur Le Pen mais moi je voudrais
rappeler que ce pays a été dirigé depuis
des années par un certain nombre de
partis politiques le Parti communiste le
Parti socialiste le RPR et l'UDF et que
s'il y a des problèmes en matière
d'immigration madamees messieurs c'est
parce que ces gens-là ont été incapables
de résoudre le problème incapable même
de le poser et si aujourd'hui Monsieur
Jacques Chirac vient de proposer des
solutions depuis 15 ans ou 20 ans c'est
parce que le Front National a infligé
une cuisante défaite alors je vais dire
une chose la démocratie ça implique que
on se met autour d'une table et que l'on
parle que l'on parle coram populo devant
le peuple qui est le souverain de ce
pays et que bien sûr on n'est pas que
des opinions favorables les uns sur les
autres on est là pour débattre or ces
gens-là se dérobent au débat et tous les
citoyens vont avoir à l'égard de cette
attitude quel qu'en soit le prétexte une
attitude de rejet je rappelle que Madame
Stirbois adreux a écrasé le candidat de
la bande des quatre par 62 % et je vous
écraserai monsieur tapis à Marseille si
vous aviez le courage de démissionner de
votre mandat et de vous représenter mais
attendez c'est pas parce que vous avez
une grande gueule et vous criez fort que
vous
arrivezur vous êtes sorti des bffond on
le sait vous poli vous avez dû apprendre
à parler depu sor c'est que c'est pas
parce que vous affirmez fort quelque
chose que ce que vous dites est vrai
parce que vous dites n'importe quoi vous
êtes en train actuellement de commencer
accuser de nouveau la bande des qu les
qu sont pas là moi je suis là pour vous
répondre à vous qu'est-ce que vous avez
com
Var la possibilité de vous répondre et
on parle enfin s'il vous plaît de
l'immigration par c'est le sujet soir
démissionné de Marseille la réponse de
Bernard voilà le macho marseillais
démissionné un peu pour vous l'avez dit
attendez on parle un dernier instant la
réponse de Bernard tapi à Jean-Marie Le
Pen et on parle enfin s'il vous plaît de
l'immigration avec vous deux mais aussi
avec un ensemble de représentant ils
sont SEP ici ils représentent les
couches sociales les plus différentes
vous vouliez parler du peuple voici le
peuple ici avec des gens qui sont
d'origine extrêmement diverse des gens
qui peuvent penser comme vous vous vous
en rendrez compte Monsieur Le Pen
d'autres qui ne pensent pas comme vous
vous d'autres qui pensent comme Bernard
tapi alors c'est le cas précisément de
l'un de nos invités qui s'appelle Salim
cassette qui a obtenu la nationalité
française par mariage c'était je crois
en 83 vous êtes marié avec une auvergate
vous vous êtes arrivé vous êtes né en
Algérie vous êtes arrivé avec votre père
qui était ouvrier chez Citroën et vous
êtes aujourd'hui adjoint du directeur du
service de cardiologie du CHR de Lille
et vous êtes également depuis mars 89
donc depuis mars dernier maire adjoint
de roubet alors vous avez siégé au dans
la Commission du code de la nationalité
c'est pour ça que vous n vous nous
intéressez vous assez proche des des
thèse de France plus sur sur
l'intégration en tout cas vous êtes pour
l'intégration et vous ne refusez pas le
débat avec le Front national alors je
vis que vous commenciz à débattre vous
donniez votre point de vue sur
l'immigration je crois monsieur le P
c'est comme ça que vous appelle les
enfants je suis même le modèle de
l'intégration je suis né en 1951 dans un
petit village de
kabili sur cette terre qui était
l'Algérie qui était un département
français et en
1951 alors que l'Algérie é un
département français je n'avais pas le
droit à la nationalité française à part
entière monsieur le P je le sais
Monsieur et j'ai combattu contre cela je
suis le petit Benjam d'une fraterie de 6
mais mes cinq petits frères et sœs mes
cinq grands frères et sœurs sont morts
parce qu'il n'y avait pas de
médecine mes grands-parents mes parents
étaient une alphabète alors que nous
étions dans un département français mon
père m'a fait venir en France pour
justement m'éduquer pour m'apprendre
pour que je ne sois pas un alphabè comme
lui
et l'école de la République m'a appris
ce qu'était le franceç
et c'est comme ça que j'ai franchi les
différentes étapes et je rends
aujourd'hui un grand hommage à mes
maîtres qui m'ont formé qui ont fait que
je suis le fils de la communale monsieur
le pin qui ont fait que mappelle
Monsieur Le Pen Le Pen ah oui ah je
croyais que vous étiez un spécialiste
des boutades ah oui hein seulement quand
on vous les f quand on vous l'aimz à
vous ouii c'est ça pas tout à fait
encore mais non non non non Monsieur Le
Pen je suis cardiologue je suis pédiatre
j'ai une formation non non non monsieur
non quand vous dites que je ne que je ne
maîtrise pas la langue
française je suis prêt à débattre devant
vous oh vous en avez écorché tellement
que vous devriez dans ce domaine être
extrêmement modeste revenant à à partir
de cette parenthèse fermons la
parenthèse en
1974 je n'ai pas pris la nationalité
française parce que mon objectif était
de retourner ce n'est qu'en
1983 lorsque j'ai fini l'internat des
hôpitaux de Paris parce que je suis
ancien interne des hôpitaux de Paris
monsieur leupen c'est à ce moment-là où
je devais partir que je me suis rendu
compte Monsieur Le Pen que j'étais
Français à part entière c'est à ce
moment-là Monsieur Le Pen que je me suis
rendu compte que malgré moi je j'étais
français tout simplement parce que
j'avais des maîtres qui m'ont appris qui
m'ont fait aimer la France je pense que
s'ils avaient eu des maîtres comme vous
monsieur Le Pen je serai certainement
retourné en Algérie je vais demander à
chacun de respecter ces temps de parole
aussi bien dans le public je voudrais
rappeler qu'aucun aucune des personnes
qui qui sont présentes n n'est
représentant de de quelques organisation
et Dieu sait si elles sont très
nombreuses à nous avoir demandé à
participer à ce débat mais nous avons
voulu faire le débat sur le terrain avec
vous vos opinions opinion sur
l'immigration sur l'intégration ça me
paraît assez essentiel Jean-Marie Le Pen
voilà le type même de français que vous
que que vous avez envie j'imagine de
garder dans le GIR
endu pour me battre pour l'intégration
que Monsieur Casset en 84 d'crouve qu'il
était devenu français moi je croyais
qu'on pouvait faire des Français avec
les Algériens c'était d'ailleurs
conforme à notre
Constitution et je me suis battu je me
suis battu même les armes à la main
contre le FLN qui lui en égorgeant ses
compatriotes et les pieds noirs voulait
imposer sa loi qui était l'indépendance
et je voudrais dire à Monsieur cassette
que ceux qui étaient responsable du fait
qu'il n'est pas appris le français ce
n'était pas le Front national ni
Jean-Marie Le Pen c'était les gens dont
il est le colistier aujourd'hui à roubet
c'était le Parti socialiste le MRP le
Parti communiste qui avait eu toutes les
responsabilité politique dans ce pays je
vis rappeler que le maire de rou je
voudrais rappeler et je voudrais
rappeler mais je voudrais parler si
c'est
possible V rapper que j'ai été le
premier Français à proposer la
candidature d'un français musulman
d'Algérie aux élections législatives
vous n'en êtes encore qu'aux élections
municipales monsieur cassed c'était
Ahmed jebour en
1957 à Paris que aux élections
européennes en 1984 j'ai mis sur ma
liste un homme qui s'appelle appel mat
Kawa un français un Français qui n'avait
pas attendu 1984 pour être français qui
lui aurait été député sans la félonie
d'un de mes colistiers qui s'appelait
monsieur dormesson j'ai fait lire madame
madame dbour comme conseiller régional
d'Île-de-France il y a déjà plusieurs
années j'ai fait élire d'autres
musulmans d'Algérie français et je me
suis battu pour l'intégration monsieur
Stoleru m'a reproché mais il ne il
oubliait que je me battais pour des gens
qui avaient la nationalité française
pour qu'il soit comme de Gaul l'avait
promis des Français à part entière
répondez vous ne les aimez pas beaucoup
les musulmans sur le fond de votre pensé
mais j'en ai tout plein autour de moi je
m'étonne de ne pas voir là un certain
nombre de musulmans français notamment
tous ceux qui avaient choisi de lutter
avec la France contre le FLN qui ont eu
leur famille égorgé 150000 arquis
égorgés par le F et qui et qui ne sont
pas là son pas pas représenter alors
qu'il représente plusieurs centaines de
milliers de Français qui eux n'ont pas
attendu 84 pour se sentir français
personne n représenté par personne à vos
côté Jacques rosau Jacques rosau se
trouve être l'un des porte-paroles du
recours c'est un mouvement qui l'a fondé
il a fondé ce mouvement c'est un
rapatrié donc c'est quelqu'un qui
devrait vous apparaître sympathique dans
la mesure où il défend je crois beaucoup
la cause desarquie et si nous l'avons
invité c'est parce que lui a vécu avec
des musulmans en Algérie et qu'il est
arrivé un jour comme beaucoup à partir
de 62 en France votre témoignage oui ce
que je voudrais dire c'est qu'il ne
s'agit pas non plus de refaire la guerre
d'Algérie parce que j'entends mon voisin
de gauche se lancer encore dans un
procès de l'Algérie française qui m'est
cruel parce que peut-être qu'il a
souffert de certaines conditions
socio-économiques c'est vrai que la
France n'a pas tout fait en Algérie mais
c'est vrai aussi qu'elle a fait beaucoup
et qu'elle a tiré l'Algérie de
l'obscurantisme médiéval de l'Algérie
qui était ass servie par les Turcs pour
en faire quand même un État moderne et
lorsque nous sommes par parti dans des
conditions d'ailleurs lamentables et
honteuses en 1962 qui sont un peu la
source et la raison et les raisons de la
situation de l'immigration aujourd'hui
que nous connaissons dans ce pays la
France a quand même réalisé un certain
nombre de choses et moi j'ai vécu dans
un petit village d'Algérie et à Alger
dans un petit village qui s'appelit nov
près de chergel avec au milieu de
populations musulmane avec lesquelles
nous avions des liens fraternels ces
musulmans ont été à l'école avec moi je
les ai connu sur les bandes de l'école
sur les bandes du lycée du verrier de
Blida je les ai connu dans le dans mon
unité de tirailleur dans le
Constantinois où j'ai fait la guerre
d'Algérie pendant 28 mois puisque j'ai
remplis mes obligations militaires de
bons français et je regrette aussi
effectivement qu'il n'y ait pas de
représentants de la communauté Archie
française musulmanes rapatrié ou de
leurs enfants qui elle aussi est menacée
par ce problème de l'intégration qu'elle
n'a pas réalisé car la France qui
aujourd'hui prend conscience brutalement
de ce problème de l'immigration qui est
effectivement un problème extrêmement
grave car il ne faut pas oublier que
nous avons une façade méditerranéenne
qui habité aujourd'hui de 60 millions de
personnes qui qui sera demain de 100
millions de personnes et qui va être
confronté à des problèmes
socio-économiques dramatiques et qui va
vont être conduits à venir sur les rives
de nos de nos pays d'Europe et notamment
de la France donc pour ne pas avoir fait
l'intégration de l'Algérie française
c'était notre idéal au moment du 13 mai
auquel j'ai participé il ne faut pas
pour autant faire l'intégration
algérienne ou la désintégration
algérienne de la France donc pour
l'intégration ok une certaine
intégration dans la dignité respective
mais il faut aussi que nos nos amis euh
de confession musulmane la souhaitent
cette intégration il faut pas qu'il se
laisse aussi emporter par ces
islamisants intégristes qui dominent
absolument le terrain actuellement et
auquel malheureusement une certaine
classe politique a donné raison il faut
aussi qu'il veuilleent bien participer à
la vie française tout en respectant
leurs différences mais en ne remettant
pas pas en cause les valeurs et
l'identité nationale française
fondamentale pour notre pays un petit
mot avec Bernard tapi et ensuite je
voudrais qu'on qu'on aborde le problème
de l'immigration clandestine Bernard
tapi d'abord deux choses la première je
suis content de savoir et et c'est vrai
ce que Monsieur Le Pen dit c'est vrai
parce que j'ai retrouvé un texte de lui
quand il était député et ça va tout à
fait dans le sens de ce qu'il
dit il peut pas lire ça dans ses
meetings hein a déjà lu ou non mais ça
fait rien il y a qui l'ont pas entendu
il y en a qui l'ont pas entendu ce qu'il
faut dire aux Algériens c'est pas qu'ils
ont besoin de la France mais que la
France a besoin d'eux c'est qu'ils ne
sont pas un fardeau ils sont une
dynamique et le sang jeune d'une nation
française dans laquelle nous les aons
intégrés j'affirme que dans la religion
musulmane rien ne s'oppose au point de
vue morale à faire croyant donc c'est
vrai qu'il était pour l'intégration et
donc il y a plus de raison qu'il fasse
chauffer ses meetings en donnant des
musulmans à manger au au au au
fanatiques du Front national parce qu'il
est pas
gresitre monsieur vous AZ dit
attention dites pas ne dites pas
d'énormité comme ça et ne me menacez pas
physiquement monsieur il vous en cuirez
parce que vous avez votre garde du corps
là rigolo enfin regardez-vous alors vous
veriez un peu que c'est lour ch deuxième
chose deuxème chose vous avez dit tout à
l'heure monsieur
oui vous AZ vous avez dit tout à l'heure
quelque chose qui me semble
effectivement fondamental car c'est ce
que l'on vit à Marseille on vient à
Marseille lorsqu'on ne veut pas refaire
la guerre d'Algérie on revient à
Marseille une relation extraordinaire
entre les rapatriés d'Algérie et les
Algériens et on la vit dans un dans dans
une relation qui est extrêmement
constructive et qui est tellement
constructive que finalement quand on
regarde les Français d'Algérie et les
Algériens lorsqu'ils étaient ensemble
s'entendaient très bien il y avait aucun
problème ni d'intégration ni de problème
relationnel par conséquent c'est vous et
pratiquement vous seul qui pouvez mieux
nous aider à ce que cette intégration
existe pourquoi parce qu'il y a 400
foyers de problème il y a pas un
problème général en France de
l'intégration ou de l'immigration il y a
400 endroits ponctuels qui sont
d'ailleurs socialement très identifié et
qui pose problème et lorsqu'on met les
moyens le temps la volonté et le talent
ces bastions là disparaissent il y en a
déjà une vingtaine qui sont disparus et
moi j'ai rencontré dans une réunion je
l'avoue secrète parce que je l'ai
organisé des représentants du FLN et des
anciens condamnés à mort de l'AS qui se
sont retrouvé qui se sont parlés qui se
sont dit mais on est en train de rater
une occasion extra ordinaire d'apporter
à ce pays une carte fondamentale c'est
une culture complémentaire pour gagner à
la fois sur le plan économique sur le
plan politique une influence dans un
monde énorme alors ne nous agitez pas le
le drapeau de l'intégrisme parce qu'il
existe pas au point où on en fait
aujourd'hui le bastion de l'immigration
il y a eu 20 20 jeunes filles il y a
500000 gosses qui vont à l'école il y a
eu 20 jeunes filles avec un foulard ça a
fait 600 he de télévision monsieur re
vous le savez car je sais que vous êtes
un homme raisonnable a pas d'intégrisme
en
franceintégrisme existe quand même il
faut pas l'ulter complètement point que
l'alééé moi je connais les photos de
l'OM ils sont tous ensemble il
s'engueulent pas ils sont tous ensemble
sagit pas de grossir le phénomèneag de
prendre en compte il s'agit aussi de ne
pas oublier monsieur tapis vous qui êtes
au portes de la Méditerranée de pas qu'
a une pression migratoire très forte du
Maghreb qui sera de 100 millions
d'habitants bientôt avec finalement une
situation économique qui n'a pas l'air
de vouloir tellement décoller et qui va
nous exporter ces pauvres qui vont être
de plus en plus nombreux et c'est là
aussi qu'il faut que le gouvernement
sache prendre de
véritabl
arrêux juste un petit mot s'il vous
plaît j'aera laissez-moi conduire ce
débat et vraiment chacun aura le droit
de parler ne vous inquiétez pas
simplement vous évoquiez les foyers de
problème il y a un foyer de problème que
vous vous dénoncez très souvent c'est le
problème de l'immigration clandestiné
nous avons voulu voir avec David Pujadas
comment cela se passait concrètement
regardez je vous demande également de
continuer à faire attention à au
pakistanais sri-lancais avec des
passeports anglais il y en a toujours on
en revoit toujours un petit peu alors
vous restez vigilant là-dessus également
sur le problème des attestation
d'accueil continue un petit peu sur les
attestations d'accueil pour les pour les
maghrébainsestation séance quotidienne
de consignes pour les agents de la
police de l'air et des frontières
d'orli la mission elle reste la même
faire barrage aux clandestins détecter
les faux touristes les faux saisonniers
qui viennent en fait s'installer en
France cette dame par exemple n'a pas
tous les papiers exigés
elle est présentée avec beaucoup
d'autres à un inspecteur son cas va
finalement s'arranger l'enfant est né
sur le territoire il n a aucun problème
vous le prouvez donc vous pourrez
rentrer avec l'enfant sans aucun
problèmeac pourtant personne ici ne se
fait d'illusion vu l'effectif un
contrôle approfondi de tous les
passagers prendrait une heure par vol
l'aéroport serait vite bloqué il arrive
même que les personnes refoulées en
attente de rapatriment s'échappent de
cette salle de transit où une seule
personne les surveille ici comme sur
chaque poste frontière les discours de
fermeté se heurent à la réalité à moins
de bâtir un mur les frontières de la
France ne seront jamais étanches un
dispositif policier n'arrêtera jamais
l'arrivée des clandestin et c'est parce
que il y a des secteurs qui en
permanence font appel à eux qu'ils
arrivent et qu'ils continuent d'arriver
et que queles que soi les méthodes de
répression de fermeture aux frontières
il y en aura et ils trouveront tous les
moyens de venir même si d'ailleurs c'est
très difficile pour eux les clandestins
arrêtés sur le territoire sont placés
dans des centres comme celui-ci dans la
l'attente de l'expulsion en fait une
fois sur deux ils seront relâchés soit
parce que l'administration n'a pu
déterminer leur nationalité soit parce
que le pays d'accueil refuse de les
recevoir soit parce qu'on manque de
policiers pour les escorter comble de
l'hypocrisie aujourd'hui
l'administration fabrique elle-même des
clandestins en la personne de demandeur
d'asile débouté car la procédure
aujourd'hui engorgée peut durer des
années des années au cours desquelles le
demandeur s'installe en France travaille
scolarise ses enfants difficile donc en
cas de réponse négative de l'expulser
mais l'administration refuse aussi de le
régulariser il est transformé en
clandestin officiel sans droit au
travail étrange paradoxe qui consiste à
plaider la fermeté et l'intégration et à
laisser subsister voir à créer des
situations précaires la politique de
lutte contre les clandestins se cherche
aujourd'hui de nouveaux outils et
surtout une vraie
cohérence et n'oublions pas selon un
sondage BVA qui est paru justement hier
dans en Paris Match que 68 % des
Français ont estimé qu'on avait
aujourd'hui atteint le seuil de
tolérance en matière d'immigration et
que 24 % pensent le contraire alors
Monsieur Linet vous êtes un homme qui
habitait Dreux vous avez je suppose voté
pour Marie-France Tirbois aux dernières
élections une de nos journalistes jeun
vif galet qui vous connaît m'a dit voilà
un pépinérist qui lui pense des tas de
choses et qui n'hésite pas à le dire
devant une caméra alors dites-nous
pourquoi un vous n'aimez pas les Arabes
deux pour pourquoi vous trouvez qu' a
trop en France j'aime pas les Arabes bon
c'est prier ça je suis venu en taxi de
la guerre Monparnasse à Paris ici là
avec une chauffeuse de taxi arabe alors
j'ai rien du tout qu les Arabes mais
trop c'est trop vous êtes de ceux qui
pensent queun seuil de tolérance est
arriv dans ce pay TR c'est trop Monsieur
Bernard tapi j'aiécouté tout à l'heure
Bou boum ça allait faire toc toc c'est
pas ça la politique je pense pas
toujours nous àreux ce qu'on veut c'est
être tranquille mais trop c'est trop
vous avez des petits villages comme
Anette presque pas d'habitant beaucoup
de retraité Marie France Stirbois a fait
60 et quelques pourcent des voir un
autre village à côté de ce n je elle a
fait 80 et quelques pourcent des bois il
y a pas un émigré dans ces petits paysl
mais trop c'est trop les tr/ des
commerçants monsieur le monsieur Bernard
tapi de Dreux ferme leur portes ta le
soir parce que voilà les les gens du
commissariat de police quand ils vont
traîner vers les chabars àreux ils
prennent des caillot sur leur
voiture non je répondre l'avis de sélime
cassette celui de Bernard tapille et
ensuite de Jean-Marie Le parce que
Monsieur monieur pourour je suis en
politique complètement
heououi mais vous nous avez intéressé
parce que justement vous avez fait
partie de ces gens 61 % rappelons-le qui
dimanche dernier ont voté pour la
première femme député du adreux pour
l'instant vous souffrez personnellement
de de de la présence des immigrés
vousvez beaucoup de trop monsieur oui
mais bien sûr mais c'est c'est
d'ailleurs ce qui est dénoncé par tous
les commerçants de Dr vous diront les
commerants de je suis venu de chez moi
hier j'ai eu comment s'appelle les de
avanti j'ai changé les de pneus de ma
voiture parce qu'il était crevé ce qui
est étonnant d'ailleurs ce qui est
étonnant c'est que justement àre les
plus forts SCOR les plus forts SCOR de
Madame Stirbois qui sont des scores très
impressionnants dans des endroit où il a
pas un imigré mais par contre
génér ils ont parfaitement peur de tout
ce qui peut se passer et qu'on le
raconte qui va se passer vous abordez
dans ce vous venez de dire trois sujets
dont il faut parler séparément c'est le
sujet de la promiscuité non non non mais
Monsieur L tout vous a
parl la parole juste après lui vous avez
trois sujets que vous avez abordé je
voudrais qu'on les aborde après dans un
débat loyal c'est le problème de la
cohabitation comment on cohabite avec
quelqu'un qui est pas qui vous ressemble
pas qui est pas le même que le vre que
vous deuxièmement économiquement est-ce
qu'il y a une relation économique entre
ils sont là ou Nil sont pas est-ce que
je suis plus riche ou moins riche et
troisièmement la sécurité voilà en fait
les trois problèmes que les gens adreux
se posent et pour lesquels on leur donne
comme réponse s'il y a du chômage c'est
à cause des immigrés s'il y a de
l'insécurité et si par conséquent vous
êtes plus tranquille dans votre ville ou
dans votre rue c'est parce qu'il y a des
immigrés et troisièmement il y en a trop
j'en vois trop ils ont des bobines qui
vous reviennent pas forcément et que
quand il y en a un peu ça va quand il y
en a beaucoup ça va pas c'est les trois
sujets dont il faut par monur tapi unee
pard pardon monsieur tapi une ville
monsieur monsieur Linet Jean-Marie Le
Pen voudrait répondre parce qu'il y
avait trois sujets donc trois réponses
de jeanmie Leen répond je voudrais poser
je crois que nous sommes en train de
nous engager dans une impasse parce que
nous parlons de l'immigration dans ce
pays et des dangers qu'elle représente
comme s'il s'agissait exclusivement des
Algériens ou des maghrébains le le
problème a une toute autre dimension que
celle-là et est lié comme l'a dit tout à
l'heure d'ailleurs monsieur roseau au
problème démographique mondial d'un côté
en Europe et en France
une une insuffisance de natalité et une
baisse de pression démographique et dans
le tiers monde une explosion
démographique mais les réservoirs
humains qui alimentent l'immigration
aujourd'hui et qui l'alimenteront demain
si on suit la politique du gouvernement
ce ne sont pas seulement les 100
millions d'habitants du Maghreb il y a 1
Millard 300 millions de Chinois 1
milliard d'hindou et on vient en France
de tous les continents du monde de
Turquie du bangladèch du Pakistan
d'Afrique noire d'Amérique du Sud et
nous sommes véritablement menacés par
une vague une submersion n nous nous
risquons d'être submergés car quelle est
la raison pour laquelle les immigrés
viennent en France mais historiquement
ça a toujours été le cas vous savez du
travail il n'y en a plus depuis 74 date
à laquelle d'ailleurs l'immigration a
été interdite en France mais pour
trouver les avantages sociaux que nous
leur fournissons dans le domaine du
logement des hôpitaux de la scolarité
du travail et cetera or en augmentant
ces ces avantages sous le prétexte
d'intégration on va
réaspirer en quelque sorte des vagues
nouvelles de l'immigration et c'est
pourquoi la politique apparemment
humanitaire de du gouvernement va avoir
pour conséquence dramatique que les
français risquent de n'être plus en
France chez eux et c'est ça le sens du
vote de Dreux de Marseille de salon de
de villeenuve d'Asque c'est-à-dire de
tous les endroits où les Français
estiment comme ce citoyen français que
trop c'est trop alors je voudrais vous
dire c'est ça qu'il faut faire savoir et
je vous assure que ça c'est si on n pas
fait comprendre si dans cette
émission je suis arrivé à faire
comprendre à quelques personnes ce que
je vais dire j'aurais bien fait de
venir ce ne sont pas les immigrés qui
créent le
chômage je certifie sur l'honneur que
c'est pas vrai que plus de 15 emplois
d'immigrés font à peine un emploi direct
de non immigrés mais par contre tout
l'encadrement descend d'un cran
autrement
ditueer d'alimenter la haine des gens
qui sont déjà durement touchés par le
fait qu'ils ne travaillent pas ce sont
des gens fragiles psychologiquement
humainementue à leur dire et à leur
faire manger de l'immigré en disant et
en désignant le responsable c'est
celui-là c'est criminel parce
que alors tant mieux si vous êtes
d'accord avec moi tant
mieux dites comme moi que c'est pas à
cause de Ch c'est un mensonge Politi
comm Mo
pasong jamais vous ne m'avez entendu
faire reposer sur les immigrés ou sur
l'immigré mais sur les responsables
politicien
vous
industriel l'outil industriel moi je
peux en parler mais oui modernis vous
les entreprises en faillite pour un fr
il vaut mieux çaériter il vaut mieux
çaériter ou pourquoi j'ai pas honte vous
sazsieur tapis moi je n'ai pas été
condamné en correctionnel pour esqu dans
mon
métier même si
c'estésenteur
industriel et c'est très important parce
qu'on sort du tunel on est en train de
sortir du Tun pendant des années tous
les pays ont installé leur productivité
sur une main d'œuvre pas chère tout le
monde l'a fait sauf les pays détruits
parce que les pays détruits il a fallu
qu'on reconstruise un outil de travail
moderne mais tout le monde l'Angleterre
l'Italie la Hollande l'Allemagne tout le
monde l'Allemagne partiellement parce
que l'Allemagne était détruite on est en
train de sortir du tunnel ça veut dire
que la rigueur dans laquelle on est
entré nous a obligé de faire deux choses
qui sont difficilement compatibles et
qui font des sinistrés c'est d'un côté
les locomotives doivent aller fort
devant pour pas se laisser distancer par
les plus performants mais d'un autre
côté plus ça va vite devant plus il y a
de laisser pour compte derrière on est
mal heureusement on est sorti du col on
est sur un faux plat on a donc
maintenant un peu plus le temps je crois
et les moyens de recoller ceux qu'ont
pas pu suivre le rythme c'est ça le
problème lorsqu'on aura recollé cela
l'ensemble des problèmes liés à
l'inégalité dont l'immigration sera
[Musique]
réglé